the graph of the line 2y plus 3x equals
7 is given right over here determine its
x-intercept so the x-intercept is the x
value when y is equal to 0
or it's the x value where our graph
actually intersects the x axis notice
that notice right over here our Y value
is exactly 0 we're sitting on the x axis
so let's think about what this x value
must be well just looking at it from
just trying to eyeball a little bit it
looks like it's a little it's a little
over 2 it's between 2 & 3 it looks like
it's less than 2 and 1/2 but we don't
know the exact value so let's go turn to
the equation to figure out the exact
value so we essentially have to figure
out what x value when y is equal to 0
we'll have this equation be true so we
could just say 2 times 0 plus 3x is
equal to 7 well 2 times 0 is just going
to be 0 so we have 3x is equal to 7 and
then we can divide both sides by 3 to
solve for X and we get X is equal to 7
over 3 now does that look like 7/3 well
we just have to remind ourselves that 7
over 3 is the same thing as 6 over 3
plus 1 over 3 and 6 over 3 is 2 so this
is the same thing as 2 and 1/3 another
way you could think about is 3 goes into
7 two times and then you have a
remainder of 1 so you still got to
divide that one by 3 so it's two full
times and then a 1/3 so this looks like
2 and 1/3 and so that's its x-intercept
7 7/3 if I was doing this on the
exercise on Khan Academy it's always a
little easier to type in the improper
fraction so I would put in 7/3